think what we did during covert could
usher in our version of a social credit
system oh yes definitely yeah and that
is highly probable
and that it will be accepted by many
people because again
yearning for safety no they won't notice
even people have no idea it's like well
why not have a digital passport
I mean you know how convenient like fair
enough and you can understand that
wouldn't it be nice if we could pay for
everything with our phones it's like
wouldn't it be nice if the central
government who's woke oriented and makes
carbon dioxide remediation the priority
knows exactly what you spend on
everything so they can Target you tax
wise with Precision it's like oh didn't
think about that it's like yeah
yeah you sure didn't and then a certain
amount of people as Jordan's laying out
will one day after the digital passports
are in and all of the stuff they'll get
to the airport they'll scan their thing
and the Machine will tell them no you
can't get on that plane
you liked this video